what's up people first of all I cannot
believe I'm on TED talk this is a big
deal because right now everybody in my
village is watching this and so of
course my bride price just went up
my name is IDO laughs I am I'm from
Nigeria I live in the u.s. I'm a
journalist or a comedian or a satirist
anything you want me to be really I'm
every woman it's all in me I host a
youtube show called keeping a room with
adiola now this show is a gentle
respectful and very blunt way of calling
out corrupt African leaders I don't know
which party my wife belongs to later she
belongs to my kitchen
see I basically keep it real with them
especially when they mess up which is a
lot of times if if any African official
is watching me by the way I'm not
talking about you sir I'm talking about
your colleagues yes I do this because
Africa has everything it needs to be
great you know I grew up believing that
Africa as a continent is a giant we've
got skills intellectuals natural
resources money any other continent
Africa supplies 31 percent of the
world's gold manganese and uranium 57
percent of the world's diamonds
entertain percent of the world's oil we
have no reason to depend on aid or
borrowing money from China or the World
Bank but without good leaders we're like
an ego that has no idea it could fly let
alone soar Africa is like a sleeping
giant now the truth is I'm trying to
wake up this giant and that's why I add
the dirty laundry of those in charge of
the chant our politicians religious
leaders with huge respect of course
because more than anything else
African leaders love to be respected so
I give it to them in doses on my show I
know for them
I call them my uncles my auntie's my
father's in the Lord and then I sold
them for insulting our intelligence and
it's because we are tired of the
hypocrisy and false promises
for example the Nigerian presidents
vowed to end medical tourism by fixing a
dilapidated hospitals and building us
new ones but what did he do he spends
three months receiving treatment in
London in 2017 we went without a
president for three months we were
president last for three months so then
it becomes my job to call out the
president with respect of course I said
ha mr. president it's your girl and
you're laughing you know how you talk
you have no shame I forgot to add sir
sir you have no shame
and better olam you have no fear of God
35,000 Nigerian doctors are presently
working in the u.s. the UK and Canada
doing amazing things because in Nigeria
there are well paid then under they have
the necessary equipment to do the job of
being a doctor and this is happening in
many African countries we have the
capacity to fly but sadly a lot of
African talents Asst fly straight out of
Africa to other continents for example
there's Nigerian doctor operated on an
unborn baby in Texas
also there's Madeira doctor discovered
the neurological effects of concussion
on athletes and many countries have
African athletes winning a gold medal
for them the interesting thing is we're
waiting for God to fix Africa like foreo
is not really aware I was involved I may
just look at the president of Burundi
he's jelly journalists and opposition
members but he declared national day of
prayer so that people could pray for God
to fix the country and I'm like
shouldn't he be fixed in the country oh
no no no no we want God to fix it do you
see what I have to deal with
I'm telling you Sunda is getting ready
to hit this politician something
we are better than this I want our
leaders to start taking responsibility
and stop putting everything on God God
has given us everything we need
it's right here let's use it but here's
the thing my favorite part of what I do
is featuring Africans doing amazing work
ordinary people touching lives like this
Kenyan woman 1 Gary my size the first
African woman to receive the Nobel Peace
Prize for standing up for human rights
and planting a million trees also this
Zimbabwean woman dr. Tara I trained who
must married off at the age of 14 in
exchange for a cow yet this woman taught
herself to read and write and she ended
up on Oprah show us father I want to be
a lowbrow someday so that this woman has
built schools for thousands of children
in Zimbabwe also popular British
architect david adjey has designed
spectacular buildings around the world
and his box canyon in Tanzania so we
know that it has to be the ganya Angela
fries which he ate they gave him the
inspiration to design ah maybe it's the
ninja and the low price because ninja
one is better anyway
but that is what given the inspiration
to become the great man that he is today
and while I have your attention I have
one more thing to say so please move
closer okay that's good that's good
don't get too close that's good
I don't like the way some of you portray
Africa mm-hmm I love you just some of
you you especially first of all it's not
a country it's a continent
I do not know Paul from Uganda I don't
know that big guy from Zimbabwe Nigeria
is as far from Zimbabwe as New York is
from France and it's not a bunch of
naked people in need of Western charity
you have it all wrong
lions are not roaming our streets okay
and I could go on but you are ready to
what I'm talking about so when I try to
do my job trying to wake up the sleeping
giants Africa so she could take her
rightful place on the woods arena you
can do your bit - please listen more
listen to your African friends without a
preconceived notion of what you think
that they're going to
say read African books oh my god watch
African movies what a very list learn
some of the names of a 54 beautiful
countries that's right 54 baby hit five
four all right you old it's been real
and I'm keeping it right up in here
until next time i'ma see you a little
peace out
[Music]